so one of the other incredible stories
here is as you mentioned Nicolas
murugali one of the
incredible ghee athletes and Jiu Jitsu
world not ever having done Noki uh
training or competition and so on in a
period of a year actually is
significantly less than a year Nicholas
only came about uh six months I believe
before ADCC as a phone call came from
Gordon he was just like okay Nicholas
wants to come down and train wants to
move to Austin yeah so he came down it
was it was funny I remember the first
day Nicholas came in
Nicholas virgali as you can see he's
like this tall handsome Brazilian guy
with a great personality and a wonderful
smile yeah also a super nice guy so he
comes in he sits down on the mat and
we're all kind of looking at the new guy
and
introducing ourselves and I look at him
I go buddy what the [ __ ] are you doing
here and he's like what do you mean and
I go like look at you you're like
tall and good looking you should be a
[ __ ] model not a juicy guy look at us
we're all [ __ ] up with horrible bodies
and bad personalities you're like a
you're like a happy good-looking guy you
should be surrounded by supermodels what
are you doing Jiu-Jitsu for and he just
laughed and he started um training with
us so um uh he came in now historically
he has been an athlete who always uh
pulled God this in in Jiu Jitsu parlance
for your viewers
um in in Jiu Jitsu you have the option
of sitting down to the ground you just
was mostly performed on the on the
ground you can and many athletes take
advantage of this ladies come out and
sit to the the ground position and
completely forego takedowns
um Nicholas did this his entire career
Judas who also has practiced both gee
and nogi Nicholas was a a Shining Light
in the ghee uh side of Jiu Jitsu is one
of the great champions of his era but he
had not only never competed without a
gear he'd never even trained without a
ghee so
there's significant differences between
the two there's a lot of overlap but
there's also some very significant
differences
we're talking about a sport where even
small differences can make a difference
between a guy who gets the gold medal
versus a guy who loses his first match
um it doesn't take a lot so
this was a very very tall order a lot of
his attacks involve the ghee from guard
absolutely he's in a very dangerous I
mean he doesn't just wear the geek he
really uses the key like his 90 of what
he's based around is based around a
combination of cross and straight collar
controls with with the control of the
sleeve cuff and so he really actively
uses the ghee so when it came off his
first training decisions were like oh
this he looked like a fish out of water
um in addition he had no experience of
leg locking so one of the most
significant parts of the modern game he
just had nothing
um
he had literally zero wrestling which is
half of 80cc is is based around this
so 80cc is like six months away and he
has to get ready for the ghee World
Championships he Nicholas had won many
accolades in ghee Jiu Jitsu but he had
never won the open weight division of
key worlds so he's like the first day
he's there he's like John
I want to be the first guy to win
ghee open weight and 80cc open weight
in the same year yeah
I'm like
I'm like um
yeah
uh now in my mind I'm thinking like yeah
that's never gonna [ __ ] happen you're
[ __ ] weirdo do you think there was a
degree to which he actually believed
that
is a degree
he thought it was like a certainty so
he's looking at me like yeah I'm gonna
do this so I'm like you know well
Nicholas this is uh this is very
laudable and and I I approve of your
confidence and
um but this is a difficult goal you've
set yourself perhaps maybe like 2024
would be a more realistic right he's
like no no I'm gonna do it in all
seriousness it is incredible that uh
Nicholas marigali had the gusts that
says such a nearly impossible goal uh so
what do you learn from this experience
of setting a goal that most people would
say it's just unachievable and him
actually almost doing it it's on the
surface just absolutely crazy like when
he's mentioned the goal to me I was as I
said just looking at him and almost like
disbelief I didn't want to show it on my
face
um and yet he came within inches of
actually doing it he won his first ever
gold in the open weight with a ghee and
got to the finals uh and lost a tight
decision in the finals and to take a
silver medal he wanted two Golds he got
a gold and a silver and there's a sense
in which the sheer audaciousness of of
the goal set
seemed ludicrous when it first happened
is they say this is this is insanity and
yet he came at it with a plan he came at
it with his characteristic passion and
hard work and came within inches of
doing so and there's a sense in which
you could look at it as oh he had a plan
and it failed
and yet of course no one in their right
mind would look at it that they would
say he sat on audacious goal so high
that it seemed impossible and it pulled
his entire performance up to a level
where even failure creates something
truly memorable do you encourage
athletes
or do you uh not get in their way when
they say such a goal maybe even just
forget athletes human nature yeah that's
a great question
um there's a sense in which you know you
don't want to make people delusional
that that's sad but I do believe that
if people are sufficiently
embedded in a given project if they're
committed to it to a certain degree
then you can skimp on many things in
life but don't skimp on your goals okay
because the bigger your goals the bigger
your achievements will be and even
failure as we saw in the case of
Nicholas murugali you I I I almost
frowned use the word failure because if
this is failure give give me more of it
you know falling slightly sure yeah
falling short of of um of what would
otherwise be a perfect year
um even that
still creates such a massive uh uptick
in your performance that it's absolutely
the right way to go but there is a
danger to this where people aren't
committed and simply aren't working from
a framework where they can realistically
achieve these things then it descends
into delusion and that that direction
goes towards Madness you can't have that
so there has to be
some kind of reality check here where
you have to be
uh uh
physically and mentally capable to some
degree of moving towards these goals you
can't just you know uh a random blue but
can't make audacious calls like that
it's just ludicrous but um
with with that in mind if if you're
committed and and you there's a sense in
which this is a definite possibility set
your goals high okay make big demands
yes there'll be times of frustration
there'll be more failure in your lives
than otherwise but even your failures
will be something great something
memorable see but in the near term
you would be hard-pressed to find any
data that justifies that goal because in
his case he he probably wasn't very good
at noogie in the even in the training
room
so it's like where do you look for even
inklings of hope uh we saw it in
incremental progress with each
successive competition that he was in
um his first competition uh uh he looked
good but not great second competition a
little better third competition took on
one of the legends of
uh American grappling and one decisively
so there was a sense in which it was
becoming more realistic with each outing